foreign
[Music]
so this is the Galaxy S10 and this phone
is really hot right now obviously and
one of the main reasons for that is the
display some people love it some people
hate it but there's no really arguing
that there's not really a lot like it
out there so this is a closer look at
what makes the Galaxy S10 so special
that screen so I've said in videos
before this is the best display on any
phone there are really three main
characteristics that make this such a
unique display number one the hole punch
camera cutout number two the ultrasonic
fingerprint reader and number three just
the quality of the panel itself so to
start with the hole punch cut out it's
pretty straightforward on our way to
bezel-less displays we got notches we
got smaller notches and then eventually
we got things like the fingerprint
readers moving behind the display glass
so the only thing left is the front
facing camera so in Galaxy S10 it's a
laser cut hole in Samsung's AMOLED panel
a process that's not totally unique and
when we saw the cutout in the honor view
20 but that was CD display this is of
course an OLED so this being the first
in an OLED and Samsung is really proud
of that and how precise it is and I can
vouch the hole punch is definitely a
little tighter around the actual camera
than honors also something interesting
so the Galaxy S10 has that single cut
out while the Galaxy S10 plus has a dual
cutout on the top corner I was told that
that second spot is for a depth sensor
and that this is not a second camera but
when you open the camera app on the S10
plus you get these two buttons which
looks like a normal and a wide a normal
one for one person and you click it and
the wide angle for multiple people it
seems to be two different camera angles
turns out this is literally just
cropping in on one wide angle sensor so
if you cover the right hand side of the
cutout and swap between the cameras they
both work and if you cover the left hand
side it's blocking both angles so this
button is literally just cropping in and
out of one camera fun fact the right
hand side cutout really is just for a
depth sensor for portrait mode anyway
I'll have more thoughts on how it it
looks with videos and full screen games
and just generally getting used to it
and things like that in the full review
but so far it's actually really not that
bad at all I mean despite it being
basically a notch I find it a little
less obtrusive than an actual Notch also
for those wondering this is how
screenshots look on the S10 plus when
it's drawing that animation around the
camera cutout alright so the second
distinguishing feature here is the
ultrasonic fingerprint reader underneath
the display so you remember maybe if
you're here the first durability test I
did with one of the earliest under glass
fingerprint sensors that was an optical
sensor
now I'm not going to go that far again
with sandpaper and everything because
this is my only Galaxy S10 but there are
still some unique questions now about
the ultrasonic fingerprint sensor versus
Optical so number one just around the
same page about what ultrasonic is that
means it's using really high frequency
sound waves firing off of your finger to
map the depth of The Ridges of your
fingerprint in 3D so when you hear it
like that that is way more advanced than
having the optical sensor which is
literally a tiny camera taking a little
2D snapshot of your finger when it
lights it up on your fingers on the
glass so this is more secure and more
difficult to duplicate is it faster
sometimes a little bit kinda so from my
experience if you just hold your finger
down like normal it won't seem that much
faster mostly because this is just how
we've gotten used to these fingerprint
sensors but what you'll really notice is
if you don't hold your finger down as
long or don't press it nearly as firmly
you can basically just touch the screen
for a split second and it unlocks this
would trigger an optical sensor to ask
you to hold it down for longer but with
the ultrasonic it really is much faster
if you just touch your finger just
lightly that is really impressive and of
course the fact that you don't have to
light up the display to read your finger
that is a real advantage and I love that
and it's supposed to be better at
reading your finger through dirt and
water so if your finger is wet or
something it'll work better so let's
find out
all right so I have here uh some water I
think in a typical situation where you
might need to unlock your fingerprint
but it has something on it is maybe
you're working out or something and
you're sweating so I'm going to use
Galaxy S10 and OnePlus 6t as two
examples of fingerprint readers that uh
need to be unlocked all right so let's
start with OnePlus 6t under the glass
works perfectly so that's good get some
water on my hand
unlock it
or try to unlock it
and I'm getting a good old not
recognized
and it's asking for that swipe doesn't
recognize me just with a little bit of
water on my thumb so I guess let's go to
the Galaxy S10 straight off the bat
if I dry my hand dry hand works
perfectly so I'll get some water on my
hand and
it still worked that works pretty
flawlessly let's get another go
no problem
no problem at all all right another
thing that was asked a lot in the
community forums uh when I asked you
guys what you wanted to know about
Galaxy S10 was screen protectors does
the screen protector work with the
Galaxy s10's ultrasonic fingerprint
sensor more importantly what types of
screen protectors work so I have a
regular screen protector and I have a
glass screen protector all right so the
first we'll try is this is a regular
screen protector it was made for Galaxy
S10 and you can already buy this in
stores but for right now while the
screen protector is not on it works it
doesn't even have to be a perfect
install for this demo so this may be the
messiest screen protector install of all
time but as long as I get the bubbles
out around the screen protector
fingerprint reader which I have
then it should work so I'm going to go
ahead and
yep you can use a fingerprint reader
with a screen protector
on Galaxy S10
you can try the glass one so a hint
that this might not work is you can go
into an ATT store or any carrier store
right now that's carrying this on and
you can buy a Galaxy S10
you can buy a regular screen protector
for the Galaxy S10 but they won't sell
you a glass screen protector for the
Galaxy S10 because they don't make them
so this is a glass screen protector for
the iPhone there's a couple different
types but they're essentially all the
same thing they're supposed to be
shatter resistant you put this tempered
glass over your display to give you that
extra durability but the ultrasonic
fingerprint reader I'm gonna guess right
now probably won't be able to read
through his glass so right now no screen
protector on unlocks just fine so step
one peel this layer of adhesive off
and I'm just going to put it straight
across the bottom right there
and now there's a glass screen protector
over the bottom of the phone have you
ever seen an installation this bad
hopefully not so let's see if this will
work through the glass
it knows there's a finger there
and it's asking me to cover the whole
fingerprint sensor but it's not
detecting if I take this off
so uh that's a no-go on glass screen
protector for Galaxy S10 yes to a
regular one but uh unless you want to
get one of those weird screen protectors
with a circular cut out around the
fingerprint reader uh I would say no to
Glass all right so the last big bullet
point for this display and just the
panel itself is how good it is period so
resolution 3040 by 1440 3K the
brightness is 1200 nits at its peak
brightness which is brighter than most
TVs it's 6.4 inches from corner to
corner on the S10 plus it has the curved
edges like we talked about the super
thin top and bottom bezels physically
it's Top Notch well I guess you can't
say it's it's not actually Top Notch
because the notch is not the
you get what I mean so there are two
display modes out the box it's on this
natural mode which actually to my eye
for the first time ever in a Samsung
phone actually looks a bit muted out the
box and then there's Vivid mode which is
very saturated Vivid is a great word for
it there's still that adjustable color
temperature and all that but that's the
Samsung look that you're used to also
out the box it's going to be at its 2280
by 1080 resolution instead of Max which
is to preserve battery life but if you
want that extra bit of crispiness
especially when watching video you can
go ahead and bump that up in the display
settings and enjoy all the pixels in
their 3K Glory but as of right now
that's pretty much everything you need
to know about the Galaxy s10's display
it's one of the reasons people like this
phone so much and many other Samsung
displays as I've said in the past that's
why their phones are popular but let me
know what you guys think of course this
is not the full review that video is in
the pipeline as well so feel free to
subscribe to see that when it comes out
and of course you can share this one
with those who are interested in the
Galaxy S10
thanks for watching catching out with
the next one
peace